we are about to make some monster
announcement we're really excited to
offer two new finishes gold and rose
gold and anodized aluminum now these are
going to come in both sides of 38 42
millimeter and they're paired with some
bands and some fresh new colors today we
have the biggest news & ipad since the
iPad this is the most advanced iPad
we've made by a long shot it's a 12
point 9 inch Retina display so our a 9 x
third-generation 64-bit chip it is for
the first time a four-speaker audio
system fold all day 10 hour battery life
as an 8 megapixel iSight camera it has a
FaceTime HD camera there's Wi-Fi and LTE
networking of course our great touch ID
built-in I know right now you're just
thinking how much does it cost sidewalk
well the new iPad pro starts at just
seven ninety-nine that's with 32 gigs of
memory for 128 gigs it's 150 more and as
a configuration with 128 gigs and lt
networking where Apple pencil is one of
the most advanced technologies we've
ever created in a simple beautiful form
feels like you're drawing directly on
the display took an incredible effort of
collaboration between our hardware
software and design teams and they've
done a remarkable job the new Apple TV
starts with a powerful set-top box in a
revolutionary remote it's got an
incredible new user interface the new
remote has a glass touch surface across
the top that makes it both fluid and
precise to move around now sometimes
it's better to interact on your
television using your voice show me
funny TV shows
Siri gives you a list of comedies with
Siri it'll search across multiple
content apps and give you all your
viewing options on a single screen Apple
TV comes in two models 32 gigabytes of
flash storage for 149 64 gigabytes for
199 and it joins the existing Apple TV
at $69 these are our most advanced
phones ever in fact the most advanced
phones in the world the new 3d touch
experience transforming how we interact
with our phones the strongest material
yet our 7000 series aluminum strongest
cover glass in the industry our new
64-bit third-generation a 9 chip our
second generation touch ID twice as fast
our new 12 megapixel iSight camera with
4k video editing new 5 megapixel
facetime HD camera a retina flash on the
front side so you can take FaceTime
pictures and lowlights we're very proud
to tide the new iphone 6s new success
possible chemin at the exact same prices
and same configurations thank you for
joining us